Nhân, tôi vừa đi hạm bờ pháp ở sinh biểu nghe.
Hôm nay đi bệnh biểu tin và biểu tin vi hí gì là lúc đó là vi
Rồi đẹp cho nằm phi cho nằm phí cho nằm phá lẽ stên,
Rồi đên, đừng nằm.
Mà viện nằm thì trong gia đình tôi thì không có dơ trao đối với vòng để triệu trần cả.
Nhưng mà mặc nay tôi đồng của sang nhỏ của Mỹ.
Kể về cái cách mà Mỹ đánh quân ta trung dân.
Nói tôi bị xúc lòng mạnh đất lượng đặc triệu trần mình lo có thể.
Cứ ông sẽ vợ lời quá tư cho biết gì cả.
Rồi một phí bước mò, đã đến đã khi bà hộ qua đời.
Hồi sinh biểu và tôi vừa vừa vừa yêu được ở pháp.
Đà làm một phí là bán thơ cho bà hộ.
Trời ơi, đặt tâm mấy đàn để thật hấp.
Thế khi tình cảm, nó phía, nó phải đình thật hấp.
Cảm sức nó chí em ra.
Trời khi nhận thức kì tình cảm, kì hành động, bà ghê đỏ nó.
Lời lời, vôy tú hồi nháo thành khi cóm đường với tôi trọng,
Tên thế giới với ta kính này bà hộ.
Cái làm con đường bà đi, đột nào làm bà, là một trong những lần tôi hiếp hoai là đi ra để để tìm là cô trả lời và kìa xảy pháp.
Đó là nó là hợp đi, và đặt thơ bà, to cập đường.
Đại xem của hồi sinh biểu và hồi pháp.
Và từ đầu tôi cười đến thế giới.
Bây giờ tên con sinh biểu pháp thì cũng là này sải.
Nhà mình là người viert, là mà có tổ chứ hợp có cầu để mình thằng góc được tiếp hơn và tập thể hơn và hiểu quà hơn.